there's a lot of corruption in India and
he's probably the first face that we're
seeing that actually looks like he wants
to do something about it and actually
bring economic progress this visit means
that we are connected to India we are
connected to America I'm actually quite
terrified by all these is that I think
people are forgetting that mode actually
denied entry into the u.s. before
because of the sort of violence that
happened in the state of Gujarat me
yes it did dampen is it is the
reputation the people of Wichitas
watered in three times
preme part of india cleared him so there
is no point of discussing i think a lot
of people forget about it especially
when you think about how much economic
progress he could potentially bring lot
more download the aj+ mobile app and
join the conversation available in your
App Store now